Hello. Hello. Hello.
How's it going, guys? How we doing today? How we doing? Friends,
you know, and I bet she would taste delicious. Imagine how Pon's
feet would taste when she's 18. I'll be like cinnamon and honey.
Next up, Pon. We We shouldn't try to We shouldn't try to speculate
and say, "Oh, despite Ethan saying his mental state and his actions
speaking both to him wanting to sue them no matter what, we should
actually make up this other thing that doesn't exist anywhere
to be able to do so." So he basically said, "Oh, you guys said
I was misogynistic. Well, guess what? I'm suing a black man."
Now, a ton of creators, the people in it already can get involved
and make comment, but I think a lot of big creators who aren't
involved at all, they're just like, "Yeah, thank God I'm not."
Hello. Hello. Hello.
How's it going, guys? How we doing today? How we doing? How we
feeling? How's it going? What's up? What's up? What's up? It
is
Saturday.
Saturday. Oh my god. It's Saturday, June 28th. Two days left
in the month of June. Oh my god.
And I'm back and I'm gonna look through all the Ethan stuff that
I missed. What's up? What? What's up? How's it going? How's it
going? How's it going? Oh my god. June June June June 28th
today. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. And yeah. What's What's up? How's
it going? You sure? Yeah. My clock literally says June 28th.
I don't think my computer is like totally off. Is there new stuff?
Oh, Shauna Black, I guess. Well, Shauna Black and then like uh
reactions from other people. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep.
So, we're going to check out a bunch of that stuff. Uh I'm It's
going to be like catching up on a bunch of uh interesting stuff
here today. I think it's going to be mostly Ethan adjacent. There's
some Tech Tone stuff as well that should be good. I enjoy checking
that out. Uh let me I'm just trying to get my sound levels correct
here. Let me see if I can get my sound levels correct. Briana
Woo versus Zoe Quinn. Oh. Uh, maybe we could check that out.
I don't have any links for that, so maybe we could check it out.
Okay.
Uh, yeah, I don't really have much, uh, to start the stream here.
So, dude, my OBS just keeps switching sides of my monitor. What
is happening? How is this possible? The
If I minimize and maximize my OBS, it resets onto the other side
other window. I don't Okay, that's weird. All right, I we'll
we'll we'll suffer through this. We'll be okay. We'll be okay.
Any not so erodite today? I don't know. What is there for Aerodite
content to react to? I have no idea what there is for
I just want to laugh at Thor. Oh, I Yeah, maybe we could do stop
games versus Thor. It's just a couple days old at this point,
so I don't know if I care that much. The Darius stuff could be
funny. H3 reaction. Are you talking about from a couple days
ago? I'm sure she said some really dumb. Windshift arrow key
up, left, right, switch. I don't even know what that means,
but okay.
Crazy Herets article if you want to do a quick I don't even know
what Wait, what would uh what would the Herets article be? That's
like crazy. Darius stuff is super funny. I got time stamps for
the Darius stuff. So, we will almost certainly do the Darius
stuff as well. But for the part of this stream while I'm wide
awake, I think we'll go through some of this stuff. I kind of
want to start with the Hassan reaction to the lawsuits and then
work out from there because it seems like a lot of people did
reactions to Hassan. There's also the the other big one I wanted
to do was basically people reacting to Caseyron's kind of breakdown
on stream. I did want to see that. Thought it could be interesting.
Black Irish, what's up? Thank you for the 16 month celebration.
Let's go. Let's go. Windshift left. Okay. Hold on. That my Windows
button. Okay. Windshift
left. Oh, you're just telling me how to shift like this. No,
no, no, no, no. That That's not the issue. Yeah, I know how to
snap stuff. Although, wait, no, that did work. I don't know why.
Okay. Somehow I shifted this over. Yeah, that did work. I'm aware
of like the the keys. I'm not sure why that worked, but it did.
Thank you. Wow. Dario cowering to Dan. Something was pretty funny,
too. I don't know what you mean by cowering. That seems like
a crazy thing. Uh, are there timestamps from his conversation
with Dan or should we just watch his conversation with Dan? I'm
sure somebody's got it somewhere, right? Oh, I I'd heard there's
a whole thing about how he like isn't allowing people to watch
his VODs anymore or sorry, archive his full VODs. Used to have
archive VODs. You've got her aisle. Okay. Yeah, we could take
a look at that as well. Uh I Oh, I have Pisco versus Dan as well.
Pisco and Dan are taking snipes at each other on Twitter and
it's very funny to me. It's very very funny to me. Uh I'm surprised.
This is like one of those things where it's uh what's going on
here? It's like Pisco normally gets crazy engagement when he's
fighting with people, but like you can tell it's um it's a lot
more Yeah. nothing I want to talk about Zezy, but uh I can't
tell if it's like like a lot of his audience I think is sort
of like DGG coded and so with some of his tweets about like uh
Dan and stuff, he's not getting like a lot of traction in the
way he would if he's fighting with some conservative. It's very
funny. Um those people will realize Pisco is like way better
than anything around DG in the first place. So it'll be fine,
right? Cuz Pisco is just going to be correct more often. Anyway,
uh it's it was just funny. It was like interesting to me. So
we'll check that out. First of all, first things first, we check
out the subreddit for today. Meanwhile, you're out there. You
put this on. Oh, look. It's nothing. It's literally nothing.
I don't I don't like this, actually. Why did I ever do this?
This whole thing with the Oh, this is gross.
This is gross. No, we should go like this. We should go like
this. Okay. Pisco gets five. Yeah. No, Pisco is doing well. I'm
just saying that like for the the Twitter stuff, he doesn't get
the normal engagement. I think it's funny because he has a lot
of like DG adjacent viewers who just don't don't like like his
opinions on the ETH and stuff. This is very funny. That's all.
There we go. There we go. There is the browser. Okay. Okay. Let's
check out the subreddit and then we'll go on to I'm not sure
which direction we'll go first. We'll see. We'll see what we're
feeling. Uh I don't know why this tweet keeps coming up. I've
seen a bunch of people retweet this. Is Zoran is Zoron Mdani
or is it M momi? Mom, Diani, is this guy's wife like a dominatrix
or something? What the going on?
What is this? Where were you? Uh, busy. Very busy. I I literally
don't I don't understand why the tweet is here. No, she's just
very attractive and Drew is a weird person. Okay. Yeah, Drew
is a weird person. Drew is like a total loser. I don't know.
It's very goofy. Don't forget who the true victim is. I think
I have this Teetone clip somewhere. Okay.
Techon claims he was blacklisted from Only Fang season 2. It's
the guy who you guys always wonder why I hate this guy so much.
Oh, Miskf didn't want him around. So, I was blacklisted from
Only Fang season 2. You'll never guess by who. You'll never guess.
It's Msk. You always get really mad at Misk, right? I know that
guy that you're thinking. Yeah, obviously it was him. But I thought
him and Tech were cool. What happened? Yes, it was that guy.
And you all know that guy. And no, it wasn't Soda.
It's the guy who you guys always wonder why I hate this guy so
much. I was blacklisted by that guy. I wasn't allowed to play.
And so what happened? What happened when I got blacklisted? What
did happen? I thought Asmin Gold was your buddy. Couldn't he
couldn't he work something out for you? Well, do you see the
misgif drama with FaZe? I saw like I saw some tweets about it.
I don't understand why. Basically, whenever the word FaZe FaZe
Clan like comes up in any sentence, I my interest like drops
to zero. These people have nothing relevant to say on any topic
ever. If you have a Faze Clan tag in your name, I will never
enjoy your content. I want nothing to do with it. It's like always
boring except well with Lacy. The one time where the shots got
fired by Antonio Brown outside of outside of uh Aiden Ross' party
and then you cut to them inside and Lacy looks like he just [__]
his pants. That was the one funny moment. Okay, that was the
singular one funny moment. All right. Oh, is your rage a part
of If your rage is a part of FaZe, then I would like him.
Yeah, sure, sure, sure. I'm just saying like it seems like all
the FaZe people, it's like so managed. It's so like uh prepackaged.
It's just weird to me. That's it. I All of them as people. No
idea. No idea how they are as people whatsoever. Okay. I'm just
saying that for me personally, when I like see content that involves
those people, I'm just like, "Oh, this is going to be like the
most scripted, boring I've ever seen in my life." I get that
some people like it though.
Yeah, somebody somebody uh requested Misk didn't attend something.
Ironic given Tech now complaining about Miskf blacklisting him
from things. I'm guessing that's how it came up. They got the
black version of me. A guy who grinds every day. A guy who is
nothing but kind to everyone. A guy who pulls his numbers. a
guy who is one of the best true gamers on this entire platform
in the name of Lucari
and they made him the new tech because
streamers can't exist without didn't die in ICE custody check
stream chat
uh I will do that a little bit later Reben I'm assuming so when
you put stuff in from stream chat it's almost never related to
what I'm currently doing so I will check it at some point
sorry I need to back it who pulls his numbers, a guy who is one
of the best true gamers on this entire platform in the name of
Lucari.
And they made him the new techone because these pathetic
streamers can't exist without a punching bag. What? Who uses
Lucari as a punching bag other than Lar? Lucari does like a bit
where like he he gets made fun of and that's his bit, right?
Like whenever Lucari's in a group situation, he's the guy who
like doesn't have too much ego that he can get made fun of and
it's like fine as long as everybody's in on the joke. That's
like Lucari's bit. What do you mean the new Techone? That's Lar
That's literally Lucari's bit. So Pirate Software did, but like
that wasn't that wasn't the same. That's not what Tech's talking
about. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Obviously Pirate Software did, but Tech
is not not mad at Pirate Software. That's not what's going on
right now, right? He's obviously not talking about the Pirate
Software thing, which is a totally different thing. And Pirate
Software was like just actively like denigrating Lucari with
no joke involved at all. It's like a totally different thing
cuz they all need someone to take their aggression out on. And
so they all bullied the out of Lucari just like they did to me
cuz they know I wasn't going to do anything about it because
that's the role they put for me. I was the guy allowed to be
[__] on by everybody because oh I got a farm to tone
emote so we got to talk to you like because you're tone
hilarious. Remember that time I got a hate thread for talking
trash at the trash talk tournament? I Tectton's got like some
Tech's got some unresolved issues. Okay, he's just he's just
talking about random [__] that happened from way
before and like honestly I'm positive he's not talking about
the Pirate Software thing right now. So I wasn't there and so
they all sh on Lucari, one of the best people on this platform
who deserves nothing but respect and they sh on him relentlessly
because they don't know what to do because these children
don't know how to act unless they have a target. That whole season
two made me sick.
Okay, I mean that's funny. I listen now. Yeah, it's very funny
because I have some like random Techone clips. I wonder why they
wouldn't want Teone there. I wonder if Teone has any like weird
things in his past that maybe you wouldn't want him hanging out
with your like new initiative,
you know? What do you guys think? You think there might be any
any weird things like that with Teone? Uh Shimu and Riyle both
posted some clips today that I was going to watch. Hold on. What
is this? Tech's ranking lollies and imagining what a toddler's
feet taste like. He is a degenerate freak and right-wing interloper
who will change his opinions and principles as it benefits him.
Uh, okay. Let's check it out. Next up, Palon. Dude, I feel like
if Palon were to visit me, I feel like we'd just be best friends,
you know? And I bet she would taste delicious. Imagine how Pon's
feet would taste when she's 18. Probably like cinnamon and honey.
Next up, Palon.
That's uh
Wait, him and Lucari really are perfect replacements, aren't
they? God damn.
Why? Why is this a thing that exists? And then unfortunately
is Clea perfect Unfortunately, Riyle posted another clip. I don't
know what this one is, but why is Teeone talking about a 10-year-old
anime character jerking people off? Is Clea perfect unit? No.
Is she terrible? No. Okay, she's awesome. I love her and she
definitely deserves to be a fivestar. We're gonna bust this open
right now. Sucross, you can suck him in. Clay, jerk them off.
You go in, Jang Lang. Oh, okay. That one seems a little different.
I get I get how you could accidentally say that. Hold on though.
Hold on. I don't want to defend too early. I get how you could
accidentally say that while playing a game while not thinking
about it. Okay, I get it. Work them off. You go in Jang Lang.
She is generally considered to be around 7 to 10 years old in
terms of her mental and physical appearance.
A little a little weird. A little weird. A little weird. But
the other one I think far far worse, unfortunately. Dude, why
is he okay? It's not him on his screen pulling that picture up,
right? That's that's Shimu editing that in. There's no way to
visit me. There's no way that there's no way that he pulled this
up on No, no, no. It's editing. Feel like we just be best friends.
I could tell. I can tell it's edited in and I bet she would taste
delicious. Imag
Pon's feet would taste when she's 18. Like cinnamon and honey.
Next up, Palon. This guy This gu is definitely going to be Asmin
Gold's ally. Okay. Asmin Gold's ally going forward. They're going
to make it. They're going to make some great things happen together.
Okay. Absolutely amazing things.
Cinnabon feet,
Okay, what else did I have here? So, yeah, Tech's a piece of
[__] There's going to be more Techone commentary
today. I went and grabbed his thing because what I want to analyze
is like what I want to talk about is how inhuman certain people
are and how they're like taking Casey Tron crying. I I think
Casey Trump was like crying about her um about like how these
lawsuits might financially devastate her, right? And I think
that people just like celebrate that which just seems weird to
me. Like I don't know. I get being I get being like a little
inhuman when you're like if Ethan Klein was like really or if
Asmin Gold was really even at Casey Tron and wanted to say like
you I don't care. I understand. But with Techone like you haven't
been personally wronged by Caseyron in some way. She's not like
insanely she's not doing something crazy to you, right? And you
haven't suffered from this like community or something. Like
at least e at least Ethan's got the skulls to point to, right?
When he's like super when he's super, you know, hateful towards
these people. At least he can go, "Yeah, they sent me skulls.
They called CPS. At least there's some basis for his like kind
of irrational hatred of these people, right? To be fair, she
would do the same thing." Yeah. And I would call her out for
the same thing, right? Like if she were to just say like, "Oh,
Ethan Klein's a when uh CPS gets called on his kids or something."
If she said that, I'd be like, "Oh, you're like, you're just
being evil for no reason, right? We do have to call out both
sides of this when they do that." Right? If you got if you want
to pull up Caseyron's reaction to the CPS thing, I'm sure it's
inhuman,
right? But is it inhuman to Techone is the question. And this
happens in like this community, too. People Yeah, Yayan just
got it. Kelly sucks. Like people will be so inhuman to somebody
they've perceived as doing wrongdoing, even if the wrongdoing
isn't done to them, right? And I don't I don't like that element
of that. That's like the parasocial aspect to this that gets
really weird. Like you haven't you haven't had somebody like
do something bad to you and you have this like a you have this
like burning hatred that even if the two people reconciled, you'd
still hate them forever and you talk them anywhere. I don't get
it. It's just odd to me.
She calls Techone a so that justifies it for him. Okay. I think
I think that still to me is I understand he's got uh allegations,
right? To me that's still talk when somebody's like actually
facing down financial ruin or maybe I don't know. Maybe Techone
just doesn't remember what it's like to be in like like financially
insecure in any way or something. I I don't know. I feel like
it's just so different when somebody's like uh livelihood or
possible like financial well-being is at at question.
think she was too stoned to say anything that awful about the
CPS thing. Okay, well lucky for her. I mean, it's funny that
she cried on stream. Um, I don't personally find it funny. I
I think like I find that like per I don't laugh at somebody crying
because they think their life's going to be destroyed. I I basically
just never do, especially over like internet trash talk where
she probably for her watch party had like 300 viewers, maybe
tops, right?
Um, yeah. I guess we'll have to see exactly what she's crying
about.
Yeah, Ry, you're a psychopath. We know that. When asked for comment
about the CPS call, she report responded with cough cough. Okay.
Okay. Okay. I thought you were making a serious comment. All
right. We have lots of stuff to get to. This is the other another
like random tweet I had. Oh, it's an off tweet again. Uh Asmin
drops a warning to those accusing him of weaponizing his audience.
We're going to take care of this problem. Can't guarantee results.
Might not happen immediately. I don't know. If you want to act
like a victim, maybe I'll make you deserve it. This just seemed
Oh, this is over the Caseyron thing. I think I'm going to go
over his Casey Tron reaction. Oh, maybe I shouldn't watch this.
Well, this is a part of his Casey Tron reaction. His reaction
to all of this. So, this is another person who's trying to advocate
for getting me deplatformed and getting banned because he thinks
that I'm bullying Caseyron
by saying that I don't feel sorry for her, that she's getting
sued for uh Asmin Gold is like the one guy where I go like, "Okay,
I you know what? You don't have to you don't have to be okay.
You don't have to stand on principle with Casey Tron, right?"
cuz Casey Tron did say something about him getting his mom killed
because he wouldn't walk away from the computer or something.
I'm like, okay, that's that's pretty out of pocket. I get why
he would doesn't want to, you know, from Ethan basically, right?
This is the reply. So, I don't know exactly where it is. And
so, this is Mike from PA. This is the same exact guy. He's having
an absolutely he's absolutely having a breakdown. If we keep
pushing, the problem will solve itself. Gentlemen,
I want to let you just a disgusting problem, right? Or sorry,
a disgusting statement. I don't know, dude. I can joke about
stuff like this with people who are like, um, man, I don't know.
It's like, yeah, maybe I have maybe I have a problem, too. When
I'm outside of the situation, I'm just like, bro, I would never
say this. The only person I feel like I've ever said this for,
maybe two, like Destiny and Darius, probably. But like, oh, it's
it feels different. Maybe it's not different. Maybe it's the
same. Maybe it's just all about being inside or outside of it.
I don't know. I I think it's disgusting to like post stuff like
this on Twitter, though.
Like that you could push them over the edge, right? I I think
it's different when I talk about it, but we'll see. I am going
to do my best. I'm going to try a as as well as I can and and
we're going to we're going to take care of this problem. Okay.
Uh I don't know. I I can't guarantee results, but I can guarantee
for
it might not happen immediately. It might not happen instantly.
You need to make a post for this. Yes. And um we're going to
try to get rid of these people and uh get a Twitter. Yes. Exactly.
So um I'm thinking about,
you know, a lot of these people are accusing me of weaponizing
my community. I'm thinking about proving them right.
Maybe I should do that.
Um, I think it's funny that he thinks he doesn't do that, right?
That he doesn't go and like pull up these tweets on stream. That
that's not like a version of weaponizing your community. I don't
know if he realizes you don't really get that much traction more
traction if you say like I want you guys to do this from from
like the skits, right? The people who would actually like go
and harass the people who are going to go and like actually get
unhinged on Twitter. They're going to do this and they're going
to go yes, I I understand. I hear you loud and clear, Mr. Asmin
Gold, leave those people to me. Leave Casey Tron to me, Mr. Asmin
Gold. I get it. I get it. And then we'll see what happens. I
don't know. You You get more volume, but like I don't I don't
know that these people get that upset at like reasonable disagreement
or like even even like borderline talk. I think they get mad
at like the more schizophrenic stuff. And that happens either
way. I don't know. But if you want to act like a victim and you
want to post stuff like this, maybe I'll make you deserve it.
I'm not saying I'll do it. I'm just saying I This is uh This
is some crazy.
It It just sounds How do you not hear yourself and go like, "Wait,
are we Are we the bad guys? Am I the bad guy? Hold on. Am I Am
I What? What am I saying? My So, the thing is I see these people
and I I want to show this and the reason why I show this here
is because these people
are prime bullies.
They are bullies. They are aggressive. They are bullies.
They're bullies who bully other bullies. Like you guys are all
bullies, right? You guys are all bullies. I tend to look at who's
like um who's blowing a situation up. I think Mike is a with
the stuff he says. I feel like he does things that are adjacent
to like threats of threats of violence and he gets away with
it. I don't like Mike. I don't like the things he says, but like
everybody here is a bully. That's what that's what this is, right?
Streaming is like internet high school and it's just a bully.
The bullies are like the popular kids and they they try to [__]
on everybody else. It's like it's like this is a good point,
but I don't know if I care about this point coming from Asmin
Gold, who is another one of the bullies. They are
They are awful people. They have no values. They don't care about
anything other than making people do what they want. And that's
Yeah, I feel like Asmin Gold literally just Asmin Gold is probably
one of the less intentful people when it comes to this kind of
thing, right? Like mobilizing and getting people to harass and
even just like like the thing he's describing. He's one of the
less intentful people, but he he does have a community that does
like this and he's got he's got friends, he's got people close
to him. Like I would say Techone is 100 times worse in terms
of intent than Asmin Gold is, right? And I don't think he I don't
think this is a principal position against like any bullying
on the internet. Don't go down to their level. I won't I'll go
lower.
I have no See, the thing is this is the problem when when you
give like somebody, you know, like the uh the old money, new
money conversation where it's like people with old money have
like principles that prevent them from losing their money. And
this is like a new money problem right here, right? This is a
new money problem that we're watching where Asmin Gold like he
doesn't actually care if he has money. Like he doesn't spend
his money, right? He doesn't care about keeping his money. He
doesn't have like long-term goals. You have somebody who's like
incredibly powerful, massive audience, probably doesn't actually
care about keeping almost anything he has. Probably knows that
he's like got everything he needs for the rest of his life and
he's accountable to like nobody.
It sounds awesome, but it's not awesome. It's like terrifying,
right? like this guy can do whatever he wants and probably be
fine. That when I see stuff like this,
my goal is to find some sort of way to get people like this off
the platform. Okay. All right. Um I the one thing I've noticed
and I don't know if I have tweets for this, but it did seem like
Asmin Gold was backing up TeeOne on the ban stuff like they might
do a lawsuit. And I really hope Asmin Gold looks at the folder
of stuff that Teone collected, which is nothing. It means nothing.
It is meaningless. It's not even remotely evidence of anything.
And like you could make this argument that Twitches like plays
favorites and Twitch doesn't apply their to us evenly. And there's
a real problem there, right? But the stuff that Tech used to
send to Twitch, that is nonsense. It's complete nonsense. It's
not even like I don't know that a human compiled that. It feels
like basically he said submit some links here that show that
they're like bias against me and then just didn't actually look
at any of the links.
He's a sleeping dragon. No one wants to wake him up from his
trash heap and ruin everything. Well,
he might be waking up from his trash heap. Okay. Unpop. Oh, look.
It's a Wait, why is this guy this guy follow me or something?
Why is this at the top? Weird. Unpopular opinion. I don't I actually
don't care. Doesn't like suing people. Yeah, sure. That's obviously
a good opinion, but I don't know how that popped up like that.
Okay. All right. What are we going to next? I want to get this
first video out of the way. Okay. We need to get our I'm sorry
because we need to get our Hassan is bad out of the way. Okay.
I do. We do. We believe Hassan is bad enough yet. Okay.
The Ethan Klein lawsuit just got worse. This is from yesterday.
I noticed a couple people reacted to this. I wanted to react
to it. Okay. I wanted to react to it. See what Hassan has to
say. I will say this seems pretty confusing to me. Ethan Klein
doing these like demands. That'll be another part of the stream.
Okay. It'll be a
I don't know what you're talking about, Creger. If you're not
watching the stream, you can go back to the beginning. We we
watched some tier list of like lollies or something. Yeah, we
watched that. Um
this these threats where it's like do this and maybe I'll drop
the lawsuit. Do that and maybe I'll drop the lawsuit. That seems
unhinged to me. Why would anybody clap for that? Oh, maybe if
you dance for me like this, I'll drop the lawsuit. Oh, maybe
if you dance for me like that, I'll drop the lawsuit. It's so
weird. It's so [__] gross. Like
I don't know. I don't know who told him that to do this. It's
so bizarre to me. It's so bizarre. Anyway, I think we're going
to disagree with a lot of the stuff Assan says here. We'll see.
We'll check it out. uh people who lost their minds after uh having
the slightest push back on their uh Zionist turning in the world.
Ethan Klein is apparently literally using the Donald Trump strategy
of trying to bleed their opponents dry for everything they have
to silence them. This is so insane, says onion person because
apparently he is uh looking to sue Shonda Black as well. Now
it's so transparently a a a
mechanism of of bullying people. I just can't imagine Shondaanda
Black went through and like didn't react transformatively.
But has Ethan posted like a complaint yet? Is there a complaint
of the Shondaanda Black lawsuit that we could look at today?
People through frivolous litigation and even if the litigation
doesn't go anywhere, which it won't for the record, it doesn't
matter because the point is not to actually win the the
uh the point is not to actually win any sort of like damages.
The point is to damage the opposition by putting them under a
mountain of paperwork that's incredibly costly. I I assume that's
part of the reason why he hasn't um
that's could be part of it. I think they know that they will
win statuto damages even if statuto damages are low and probably
get their attorney's fees covered at like minimum.
Um I think although Ethan is with these weird like conditions
that he's providing over lawsuits and stuff. I do think like
in my head I'm like, dude, there's no way that you can't use
this as like an attorney of Casey trying to show that this is
sort of um vexacious,
right? Like it seems bizarre, but ultimately the cases without
Ethan doing something to like fumble them, the cases are kind
of open and shut, at least against Casey and uh probably Frogan,
right? But it just seems weird when you can show so many elements
of Ethan's intent that are just like gross. Like, but but hey,
that's not that's not like me having a legal opinion, right?
Like, I can tell that he is not suing over copyright. It's not
like he's not concerned about harm being done to him. He's not
concerned about harm being done to the community. He is just
like trying to punish these people for talking about him, right?
I But hey, maybe none of that matters. Try some like this with
me and he's just going after all these other people who are much
smaller content creators who don't have the same financial freedom
to be able to do so. So he basically said, "Oh, you guys said
I was misogynistic. Well, guess what? I'm suing a black man now
and and then turned around and apparently released this." He
said, "I understand my announcement that I'm going to sue Shawn
the Black was upsetting to some. Therefore, in an act of superhuman
grace, I will make you this offer. If the snark subreddit, Taylor
Loren, and Catbarge all apologize for calling me a misogynist,
I will consider dropping the lawsuit against Shawn. This offer
expires on Sunday at 11:39 p.m. I thought this was all about
copyright litigation. What do you mean? So, he's just dangling
uh uh litigation against people? guy is gross people because
other people have hurt his feelings by correctly calling him
a misogynist. How is this just legal extortion? This is like
extortion through litigation. Yeah, this is the the last thing
I'll say about this, but Ethan Klein is using me to force accomplish
women journalist to grabble to him is ironically exactly the
misogyny he claims is inaccurate in this very post. He presents
a false choice. One, gravel to him as he exerts the control he
wants to feel over women. Two, deny him whatever gratification
he gets. I think this is such a red herring. I think like biting
into the misogyny like argument here is exactly what Ethan wants,
right? Like trying to call him a misogynist over how he's acting
here. That's precisely what he's looking for. It's how he like
bridges over to a bunch of these other communities, right? Oh,
they're calling him misogynist, but I'm just defending my legal
rights. I think I think a bunch of these people, they don't understand
like a a broader game being played here. I don't I don't like
that they're just biting this bullet and calling him a misogynist.
I don't I don't think that that is the real criticism you should
be making and Sean's like falling into the trap and it's it's
unfortunate to see from that narcissistic behavior and subsequently
be blamed by him for a smaller creator being sued. I reject this
choice. You Ethan and not even giving them the option for the
women gobling the lyrics to other women from the lawsuit carefully
crafted to only humiliate and incon inconvenience women. Amazing.
Is it legal misusing litigation like this? Guys, I don't think
you understand. It doesn't matter. It doesn't matter because
he has a ton of money. Okay. Until he is deprived of all of that
money, he can just do this permanently. Okay, that's it. Like
everyone it's it's really interesting because like everyone understands
that that this is all completely ridiculous. Some people try
to act as though there is a real purpose behind this. There's
a real way to to finally uh take down these copyright abusers,
right? That's not the case. He's just using a pat. Yeah, I don't
I was going to say the funny thing is is probably you could argue
Denims is a serial copyright abuser that she does like play alazero
whatever the right at the start of her stream. Like she is lazy
and abuses copyright, but that's not like at all what's really
a problem here.
It's like yeah, yeah, I do agree that like probably most of these
people abuse copyright. Although I don't know about Froen. Casey
definitely does. Denims definitely does. But suing them over
a case where they didn't really uh like abuse copyright in the
same way like Denims definitely didn't. I think maybe this the
stream you can argue she did but like I don't I don't know how
long she watched it for. I don't know what's going on there.
Right.
It just it's very funny to me. Patent troll method. He couldn't
do this in any other court. That's why he had to uh go and and
uh get his video copyrighted ahead of time. YouTube just responded
on Twitter. W Ethan. I mean, you could say w Ethan if you want
all React content to end on the internet and you also support
Ethan Klein lying about what his intentions are because he's
an insecure.
But like if you support both of those things, Zenj, I agree.
W Ethan, right? Lying about your intention, lying about what
you're trying to do and
possibly like ending all react content for everybody. If those
while saying that's not your intention, I think if those are
two things you're down with, I think you could say W. Ethan probably
calls for people banning him. We really appreciate you bringing
this to our attention. I'm reporting the channel on the official
reporting tool if you haven't yet. No, this is just this is automated.
This is not real. The chances of him actually succeeding
uh in court are very little. You can file California bar complaints
against this. That's not true. That's super not true. Okay, that
is totally made up. I don't know where he like literally works
crackpipe moment. Okay, like oh he's got very little chance of
winning. No, he's got like kind of slam dunk cases that he could
screw up via his own words, but like if he just shut the up and
hired a real lawyer to prosecute these cases, he would almost
certainly win, right? I think there's there's a decent chance
that if he um if he keeps like saying stupid, if he keeps um
if he continues to like turn this into a spectacle instead of
taking it seriously, maybe there's some argument that a judge
will eventually buy that this is sort of vexacious and and not
really not really like a legitimate suit in some way, right?
the the actual damages here being very very little. I do think
there's maybe a chance, but like oh my god. Yeah, it's absolutely
his game to lose. Like he has he has the ball in his court completely.
Oh, dude. I I don't know what Hassan is talking about here. Have
you seen the reacts he's suing for? Can you have an opinion that
he totally has a firm case without having seen them? Sorry. Against
Denims. Denims does get up and walk away and not talk and just
like eat her food while she is watching the stream. So I think
for the stream almost certainly like she'd be found guilty. The
issue here is that when you're found guilty and you have the
opportunity for statutory damages, you will owe those statutory
damages, right? Like that that's the issue here. I think in terms
of actual damages, the problem where you wouldn't see this being
prosecuted as a case most of the time is you wouldn't have actual
damages from this. There'd be virtually no actual damages. It
would not be worth pursuing whatsoever. But the the statuto damages
and getting your attorney's fe fees paid for, that's what gives
him um the ability to find something. It's like it's like if
there was an old law that could show that if somebody got a parking
ticket, you could actually like like 100x the cost of the parking
ticket if it was like on your property. Like if there was a law
like that where it's like, okay, basically we can confirm almost
certainly that you parked incorrectly, right? But there is some
old law that shows you can 100x that if somebody's parked in
your property and they just do out of spite, right? Like that's
it feels something akin to that. It's not even just that apparently
at JTO. They're saying that only a small portion of the react
is actually related to the content too. That's why I want to
watch it and see what she rambles about. Uh no, no, no. That's
for Froggen, I believe. And Frogan was doing other things for
Denims. I don't think that's the argument that it's like not
about that at all. Yeah, I don't think so. A lawyer for Vixaceious
litigation, I believe. Yeah, that's just a bot. You know what's
really ironic about No, that's not going to happen. No, you I
don't think you get him for vexacious litigation unless he like
really opens himself up in some way. The initial uh copyright
it was in the denim suit. Um I don't think it was one of So there
were four things in the denim suit that I remember them saying
were problems and I thought it was that most of it was like misinformation
or incorrect for commentary, right? That it was not good commentary.
Not that it was totally unrelated, but maybe maybe I'm misunderstanding.
Hold on. Let me pull it up. Uh oh, I don't like this. I hate
this. I hate this. Can I have this in like a different thing?
Hold on. Why do I not have the PDF here? Hold on. How do I open
the PDF itself?
Just give me two seconds here. Yeah, this is what I'm looking
for. Okay. Okay. So, there were like uh four things here in terms
of factual allegations
um misinformation.
Yes. So a most frequently denims will watch long unadultered
portions of the works and briefly pause to give short surface
level and often repetitive observations that provide little to
no new information, new aesthetics, new insights or understandings.
So bad commentary. Okay. Other times, Denim's commentary is little
to no critical bearing on the style or substance of the works.
She goes off on tangents unrelated. So this is the second one.
So bad commentary first, off on tangents, second uh third misinformation,
fourth empty chair which is for the stream. Okay, that's like
the order. I assume that's the strength of operations here. Strength
of operations. I assume that's like where where it's at. That's
like what they're most concerned about. Okay. All right. We continue
on with the song that he filed against Froggen, Denims, and Caseyron,
some of which are literally in the original work that uh that
he put out there, right? Is Yeah. Yeah. I guess Caseyron would
be because he doesn't like them and he doesn't like the way that
they reacted to the work. Anything else he says about this is
[__] It is a that's true, but that doesn't matter.
To try and silence criticism and under different circumstances,
he would get hit with a uh he he would get hit with an anti-slab,
but he can't hear because it's on federal courts over copyright.
He's using the one most effective method to be able to sue people
successfully, which is what patent trolls use. He's basically
behaving like a patent troll. He's behaving like like a literal
like a uh what would you call it? There there are lawsuits that
that record companies have filed against random people when they
like upload it to six different people on Napster. You give them
like six different copyright violations, right? This was like
when Napster first came about. That's like what Ethan is doing.
He's like trying to go after people. He's trying to like chill
the behavior. Right now, what behavior is he trying to chill?
Uh he's going to say, "Oh, well, it's a it's this malicious cop.
It's this malicious reaction." Unfortunately, that's not going
to be a thing that they take into account in in court. So to
stop people from reacting to his videos and not even to stop
people from reacting to his videos, but just to, you know, hurt
financially the people that cannot undergo this incredibly long
and incredibly costly process. It's just to bully them because
he's not doing this to Asmin Gold. He's not doing this to XQC.
It's not like their reaction was like uh tremendously better
than I don't know Denims or or Froggen who was primarily featured
in the work. By the way, for Froggen especially, she's literally
slandered in this work that she's responding to. That was good.
I'm in the context in the content nuke, not context nuke. In
the content nuke, even implied Froen was paid by guitar. You
got a million from that. That's what I'm talking. You think I'm
paid? What? Yeah, I wish 10 million, man. I picked 10 million.
Okay. And he's not doing it to me because again, he can't get
the same satisfaction. I'm a much larger content creator. I'm
I don't have the same like I have a lot of enemies for sure,
so he can probably galvanize them, but I'm a much larger content
creator that can put up a stronger opposition and can withstand
litigation like this. These other content creators cannot. It's
a very calculated move, but think about it. It's not like a earnest
copyright litigation. And ironically enough, if this were to
set some like new standard, some new precedent for copyright,
will Hassan have the correct point here is the question. Who
knows? Uh, in terms of like React content on the internet, this
would actually harm half snark commentary slop tubers themselves.
And yet they're still willingly joining in on the battle because
they hate the people that Ethan is bullying. They don't even
realize that this might have negative consequences for themselves
if it sets a new Well, they do, but they've like coped themselves
into thinking. Okay, they've cooked themselves into thinking
that they actually want that that that that's what they want,
right? Here's the actual outcome that's going to happen when
this happens, right? It will basically be setting a precedent
if Denims is found guilty for the content nuke. Okay? It will
set a precedent that even substantial reactions are still like
uh like copyright violations, right? It would set that precedent
and then you're basically not going to get critical commentary
on anything, right? not full watches with critical commentary.
It will be it will go back to streamers not doing that at all.
Like the age of critical streaming is not is basically nothing.
It it's it's just going to end. It's going to come to an end
completely. Sorry, I have to back up just a little bit here.
I need to answer a phone. Frankly enough, if this were to set
some not a phone call messages, new standard, some new precedent
for copyright uh in terms of like React content on the internet,
this would actually harm half snark commentary slop tubers themselves.
And yet they're still willingly joining in on the battle because
they hate the people that Ethan is bullying. They don't even
realize that this might have negative consequences for themselves
if it sets a new precedent for how content creation is is done
online. But I don't think it'll happen regardless. They already
set precedent and their own president will be used to shut down
H3 for their claim. I know. But it doesn't matter because if
that is a costly legal battle, if that is a costly legal battle
ultimately, that costly legal battle is still a victory for Ethan
because he was able to bully these people and they're receiving
death threats in the process. people are on them. All of these.
Okay, I Okay, this is not a good counterargument. Oh, these people
are bullying Froen. I I'm sorry. That is not That is not like
a good enough reason for Ethan to stop. Why? Wait, am I am I
muted? I shouldn't be muted. Why is Dung Devil saying muted?
Cuz he is not having the streamer correctly. They're like orbiters
that suck on the teeth are are salivating with like extra drama.
And I I go I go through this back and forth where I'm like, should
I not cover this at all? But als because I know that's what he
wants. Ultimately, he wants attention. He's like a petulant child,
a pathetic crybully, a permanent victim, right? But also at the
same time, it's like I don't know. This is it just I feel like
if I don't give any attention to this with my platform, it's
like then it's then I feel like I'm leaving these people defenseless.
He has also admitted multiple times he wants to hurt you financially
through them as if you were their legal guardian. No, I know.
I know. So they they all Oh, the most embarrassing thing. Okay,
I don't know if Assan I don't know if Assan was live when this
was tweeted, but there's an incredibly embarrassing tweet from
Ethan as well. Have a GoFundMe. And I think it's so funny that
now that they're competing against each other
for defense dollars and Smog the Dragon aka Hassan the Communist.
Okay, Asmin Gold's definitely Smog. Okay, I understand there's
jokes about XQC and and Hassan. Asmin Gold is like the biggest
streamer of multiple Asmin Gold is absolutely smog right now.
And he lives like this aces acidic aesthetic lifestyle where
he like doesn't buy anything. Okay, if anybody at least XC spends
his money on watches and Okay, [__] Asmin Gold is
the dragon. Asmin Gold is the hoarder. A socialist uh savior.
He is not opening his wallet. That's why he keeps saying like,
"Oh, socialist. Why won't he give these guys money?" Trust me,
if I if I offer support, you won't know about it. Okay? What
I've done thus far, you will never hear about it. And it's it's
um I wish everyone would stop talking about him. The more orbiters
on both sides talk about him, the angrier he gets. All talking
about it, does this lead to more hate to them? I know, which
is why I'm trying to play this balancing act here. How large
a part of his content is? It's his entire content. That's the
only thing. No, he didn't add me to the lawsuit because he begged
me to watch his video. He won't watch the damn video. Don't let
him get away with that,
He was nearly in tears when Hassan didn't give him attention.
It's just pathetic. I'm almost certain a lot of people have suspected
that Ethan never actually planned to sue people. No, he did.
I think he wanted to sue me. I think he wanted to make the nuke
and then when I reacted to it, sue me. I think that was his grand
design, but it failed spectacularly because I just didn't watch
it and he cried on camera. And so, can we get a can we get an
actual like announce or an actual confirmation? Did Ethan invite
Hassan to watch it before it came out or after it came out? And
how many times did he do it? Cuz I think if he did it once accidentally,
that would be interesting. If he did it like multiple times,
I'd say he probably wasn't intending to sue Hassan. probably
intending to sue the other people, begged for me to watch it,
and then when I ended up watching it months later, I watched
it for 9 hours. So, it would be really, really stupid. This is
why we need more leftists to get involved in the fight for free
speech online. There are laws that can protect against this,
but we need people to fight for them. Well, there are several
clips of E saying that he's only suing them because he's richer
than them and wants to punish them using the legal system. The
judge would throw out the claim in a second, but this is about
fin I don't I don't think that's necessarily true. I think his
motivation for suing probably doesn't matter that much he doesn't
like. So, the damage will still happen in the lead. Yeah, that's
it. Someone get legal on this? No. No big YouTuber will no big
YouTuber will tackle this issue. I'm sorry because they don't
want to go after Ethan cuz he's a maniac. Did you notice the
registration for Library of Congress was before the CPS call?
Yeah, I pointed that out a 100 times. Yeah, obviously. Obviously,
he planned to sue these people before the CPS call. Yes, that's
like the number one argument back against people who are like,
"But CPS, but Skulls, but CPS is skulls." Yeah, that he was planning
this before any of that happened. That's number one. And number
two, I don't think they like any of the people Ethan is attacking.
Anyway, you have to realize a lot of these guys, a lot of Yes,
dung devil. But it it depends on
So, it depends on basically understanding what his intent was
beforehand. If he didn't invite Hassan to react at all before,
then he probably was intending to sue Hassan and then at some
point realize, oh well, he's not going to watch it now. I'm going
to mock him for not watching it. Right. That's what I would assume.
Content creators are sharks. Only after the permission, only
after the permission structure opens up for uh after some brave
content creators actually come out and say something, big enough
content creators come out and say something. Not even myself
because again, I'm in the dangerous camp because I have uh political
opinions that uh they don't even if they agree. I mean, what
are the what are the big YouTubers? Unfortunately,
uh everybody's burned their goodwill on this. I think I think
most big creators don't want to be involved anymore, right? Like
this would be this would be like a black hole to get involved
with for like a ton of creators. The people in it already can
get involved and make comment, but I think a lot of big creators
who aren't involved at all, they're just like, "Yeah, thank god
I'm not. Thank God." Agree. They don't want to like openly go
out and defend. Even if they literally agree. It's the same as
the Cody Co situation. It took like D'Angelo Oh, look. It's a
legal mindset video on this video. Legal mindset video on this
video. We might check this out after us to to come out and make
a video for everyone else to [__] open up the floodgates.
Legal YouTubers and free speech people are extra quiet. No, there's
I think there's some legal YouTubers who have covered it, but
they're like pro Ethan. Yeah. To cover this would mean talking
on Israel Palestine, which they are not equipped to do and want
to fence it on. Exactly. Uh no, in terms of the law, it doesn't
matter what your opinion on Israel Palestine is. Actually, I
I have no idea why he just said that. That is crazy. So, from
a legal standpoint, he's right. Not necessarily. I don't even
think he has uh I don't even think these are lawsuits that he
will win. For the record, patent trolls, here's what patent trolls
do. Okay, patent trolls will sit on a patent or like will will
make like minor changes to a patent and go to large corporations
not with the hopes of like actually winning a lawsuit, but with
the hopes of settling out of court. Okay, Ethan doesn't want
to settle out of court because what could be the actual damages
that he has incurred in this process that he could settle out
of court with? Patent trolls are never the large company actually
patent trolling smaller creators or smaller inventors. It's actually
the opposite. It's people that just want to farm money off of
uh people say without anti-slap the lawsuit can't be tossed.
But I think it's still it could uh it still could due to the
misuse of the copyright system. But it's not how is it a misuse
of the copyright system.
Right. Here's the thing is like I think the fact that this is
a what do you call it? A strict liability crime. I think it that
is what makes it not a misuse, right? It ultimately just comes
down to whether or not this person actually violated the copyright
and then to what the actual damages are. Well, in this case,
the statuto damages are. And I think unfortunately, even if Ethan
just did this to be malicious, I don't think I don't think a
judge can necessarily take that into account except when like
setting fees or ordering uh like legal fees be paid. I think
those are basically the only cases. The CPS call was not the
final nail in the coffin. It was not at all. I promise it was
not large companies and for many large companies. Uh he was planning
to do this from the beginning. That's literally why he registered
it. That was what he was doing. He stated as much. We we shouldn't
try to we shouldn't try to speculate and say, "Oh, despite Ethan
saying his mental state and his actions speaking both to him
wanting to sue them no matter what, we should actually make up
this other thing that doesn't exist anywhere that Ethan has incited
that nobody else has cited because copyright claims are are uh
fairly airtight.
Large companies would rather not go through the It's because
they like to pretend enttrapment and extortion in this case is
real." Oh, I think I think like enttrapment in a moral sense
is absolutely what happened here, but I don't know that it matters
because it's a strict liability crime,
right? I do believe Ethan went and reacted back and forth and
set this whole thing up so that he would have this happen and
then Dan told him about Yes. all of the the way to register the
Library of Congress. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. All true. All true.
All true. Like he he wanted to do this. He wanted to sue them
and destroy them financially, but he found a venue where his
intent, his malicious intent probably doesn't matter, right?
Cuz realistically, I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure these copyright
courts have found in favor of big record companies against I
think the the example I think of is somebody like shared a file
like six times and they charged this guy like tens of thousands
of dollars. This guy got destroyed for it, right? So I think
because it's a strict liability crime, even if your just if your
intent intent is like broken, it's it doesn't matter. Expensive
paperwork that would be more costly to them. So they will just
pay off the person and tell him to off right cuz that's significantly
cheaper for them. But in this circumstance, you can't even tell
Ethan to by paying him because the amount that I suspect he's
demanding from these conters is insane probably. And it's insane
on purpose because the goal here is not to actually reach a settlement.
And I don't know why I don't know why
people uh uh don't recognize that. He does want to settle. He
wants them to apologize and delete their videos. No, he wants
money from them, too. An in an impossible amount of money. Rogan
said he's asking for 150k. There you go. Do you think that I
mean those are those are initial demands. Uh there there could
be like obviously a conversation there. His initial demand is
not the the amount he'll settle for, right? It's a starting point,
a valid claim. Do you think that Denims or Frogan or Caseyron
with
150k is minimum?
No. 150k is maximum. What are you talking about? Talking about
statutory damages. 150k is maximum statutory. Their individual
YouTube videos or even in their uh Twitch streams actually raised
$150,000,
stole $150,000 from Ethan. Do you think that that's what happened
here? No, of course not. The reason why that price is so high
is because settlement is impossible. 150k is the maximum allow
for law by law for copyright lawsuits. Jesus Christ. 150k is
the max he can seek from them because the law dictates the max
off for copyright lawsuits. Jesus Christ. 15k is the max he can
seek from them because the law dictates the max he get in damages.
This is not even a no that is not true. He could seek far more
if his actual damages were more. The maximum statutory damages
are 150k. His actual damages would be nowhere close to that.
So it's not it's like a move down. This is not even extortion.
I don't think you guys understand this is just legal bullying,
okay? He wants these people to suffer and he knows he can do
that because he has money. He can't do it any other way. He can't
do it the normal route. He can't just like constantly talk about,
you know, how they are because that gets boring. Where's the
pirate coverage? Uh maybe we'll get to it after this after a
while. I want to catch up on this stuff. He's trying to jam him
up with paperwork and in defense of this uh this this insane
lawsuit, he hopes that he can cause suffer and make content for
himself in the process. I think the content thing is actually
a way bigger motivator than I realized. I think these lawsuits
were basically like, "Oh, things are slowing down." Well, let's
keep the content train going. I think that's way Dude, Ethan's
going to make back even if Ethan was found like even if all of
the people he's suing are found not liable, he can pay all of
his legal fees and more just by the content he's making off of
this, right? Like he'll he can just eternally paint himself as
a victim, get a ton of donations. I think it's like a way bigger
deal than I originally realized. I think and I think this is
actually
it just falls in line with a pattern he's had for a while, right?
Where like he will get and when he gets into fights with other
creators, um he is like psyched for it to go to the legal legal
phase, I guess. Dude, legal legal content making apparently this
is like the big thing. Okay. He makes so much money out of it.
Isn't there anti-lap in California? This is not in California
course. As far as I understand, I think this is literally at
uh at think Ethan is doing a cringe Dave Portoy paid trip to
the Holocaust Museum style punishment to denims. Oh, wait. Is
that actually a thing he demanded? That'd be interesting. Uh
copyright cause suffer and make content for himself in the process.
Isn't there anti-slab in California? This is not in California
courts as far as I understand. I think this is literally at at
uh copyright claims uh happening at the federal courts. This
is not like a California litigation. It's a federal lawsuit.
That's why he actually That's why he actually copyrighted like
patented his YouTube video. Logan Paul is doing the same suit
to Coffeezilla. All this while snark subreddits and similar harassment
just caused another creator to commit. Yeah, I heard about that.
The Fox Sanctuary woman is so sad. The legal complaints are in
California for uh Denims and Froggen. Wait, what do you mean?
Call it for what it is. He's abusing the legal system the way
stalkers do. No, that's precisely what he's doing. But in this
circumstance, because the legal system is busted, because the
legal system is fundamentally broken, if you have a lot of money,
you can do this kind of thing. uh when you're depraved and you're
manic and you're an insane person and you don't care about like
wasting unlimited funds,
especially considering that uh he does technically have virtually
unlimited funds, you can be a vacious litigant. It's like having
a mentally ill stalker who has an unlimited amount of money and
power. And not only does he have an unlimited amount of money
and power, he also makes content off of this. So it it turns
into more money for him down the line given the way that our
It does suck. It does suck. I wish a judge could look at this
stuff and go like, "Oh, actually given the stated intent, I'm
basically going to award like no statutory damages." I wish that
were the case. I just don't think I don't think that's what's
going to happen. I don't think that's really that relevant. I
think he will probably if he takes these lawsuits through to
completion be awarded these statuto damages. our legal system
works, given the way that our court system works, given the way
that copyright works, there's really nothing you can do about
it other than hope that it goes away eventually. Just like cyberstalkers,
we do not have an adequate measure against cyberstalking and
just like stalking in general. We don't have the best possible
measures. So, the only thing you can do about cyberstalk
uh I don't know that they ever average like 50k all the time
forcing Yonko, but maybe is basically hope that they just calm
down, take medication,
stop stalking you. there's really nothing else you can do about
it. Even now when I'm talking about this stuff, like there's
still people chiming in to say like, "Oh, what are you afraid
of us on?" Like, there's a couple foot soldiers here and there
and and uh orbiters here and there that will come in and say
something snide, right? But there's 40,000 people in here, so
obviously that doesn't do anything to me. And plus, I eat this
on a daily basis. This is not my first foray with like weirdo
content critters in their communities. Oh, stop. Oh, there's
somebody in like the uh the waiting room here who wants to talk
to me, but I don't know what about. I don't know what is he upset
about. Hold on. I haven't even like followed this case, so I
don't know what this guy could possibly be upset about. Cry,
believe your friends. Your friends are having consequences beneath
you. Like, see, this is what I mean. It's just like the the point
here is to be a nuisance, right? Then maybe don't be malicious
and transformative. Then maybe be transformative and not malicious.
Like, they're just repeating stuff that they think sticks. If
this if you're a smaller content creator and you have this kind
of constantly in your chat, never mind. Uh this guy's just a
troll. Boring. Especially while you're also working through a
a immensely wealthy psychopath stalking you and and actively
using frivolous litigation to to harm you. And then on top of
that, their audience members because he's a larger content creator
than you are coming in to constantly point at you and laugh.
Like he wants these people to commit. Like that's what it is.
He is trying to actively stalk and harass these. Um, here's the
thing. You can't call somebody a stalker when all of these people
have been commenting on his content. Like, this is the other
side of it, right? It's a little insane to say when this back
and forth happens, when either side act like the the total victims,
it's complete, right? There is a back and forth happening to
pretend that like these people are just getting harassed for
absolutely no reason. It's insane. Okay. What? How do you frame
him as a stalker when you guys have been engaging in this back
and forth the whole time? Hassan's maybe the only one with like
slightly more of an argument, but he's also mentioned Ethan a
whole bunch. Okay, none of you are the perfect victims here.
None of you are like actually just total victims. You all engaged
in this back and forth. Stop pretending that like this came out
of nowhere or Ethan Klein trying to destroy you would have come
out of nowhere. He's not just like a mentally ill stalker in
this way, okay? He might have like some uh some neurosis that
are getting the better of him, but he's not a stalker. Okay.
Smaller content creators calling him a stalker is insane. Assad
is bad. And jam them up with frivolous litigation that he has
directed specifically to harass and intimidate them into submission
with the hopes that they will commit. And that's what his content
is now. Okay, that's it. That is quite literally this is Kiwi
Farm. Like that is precisely what he's doing. There are entire
communities on on the scary uh not often talked about side of
the internet that engage in this kind of behavior. Yeah. I I
can't believe I'm talking about this because I saw Abby Martin,
a a important journalist going, "Everything I see from this guy
is hateful and condescending, genuinely babbling. He has such
a large audience. If you did the same thing as Ethan, right-wing
would be on your app quicker than Quicksand, of course. But if
I did the same Oh, did they call him a stalker, for example?
He's literally stalking every post about Idubbbz and his wife
that he has that has nothing to do with them." Um,
no. I don't I don't think you can call him a stalker when everything
he does is getting reacted to and it's like been a loop. and
he basically he basically didn't start this, right? I don't think
it matters now, but ultimately he's not the person who started
it. Okay, he's not the person who started it. I think a lot of
other people were going after him before he had like insane opinions
on anything. Before he was like acting crazy in some way. All
right. Same thing as Ethan. be a depraved sociopath and an immensely
weak person who thinks that he can make up for whatever sense
of lost purpose he has in his own life by constantly engaging
in this kind of ridiculous quote unquote drama that is ultimately
very consequential for the people that are in the crosshairs.
I don't have this level of hatred for anyone. I don't have this
level of hatred for Ethan. I'd much rather have him be happy
and and just stop doing this. Like what kind of freak deres enjoyment
out of this? I don't understand. He'll only stop when he loses
a good chunk of his money. I don't even think so. I I think that
the only way he stops is if people just like don't give a [__]
about it at all and he is forced to find something else to do
like goofs and gaffs again. If he can never even go back to that
at all. Yeah. I mean, this was this is exactly what I mean. I
mean, this is so insane. This is from Ethan Klein's lawsuit which
is supposed to be about copy copyright infringement. Apparently,
he mentioned me like he mentions me in all of these lawsuits
like hundreds of times. In the wake of October 7th, Hassan emerges
the modern incarnation of the grand mut alsini. Like al-Husi,
Husan became a passionate advocate and highly charismatic leader
of the Palestinian cause. Like Al-Husi, Hussean uses his massive
platform to spread genocidal rhetoric about anyone advocating
for the right of self-determination in their ancestral homeland,
i.e. Zionist. The primary difference between Hassan and Alusi
is that Alusi work with the Nazis and advocated for the annihilation
of while Han advocates for the annihilation of all Zionist. I
do not since the it's uh I I don't understand how this could
possibly be relevant to his lawsuit. This was very very very
goofy. Very goofy. majority of the United States say caring about
Israel and then yeah he posted they put the footage of this like
this is this is under different circumstances like
if Ethan wasn't who he was and his targets weren't people that
like all of the grossest losers online despise and enjoy making
fun of and enjoy l cowing derive satisfaction from seeing them
suffer people would look at this and be like this is the most
schizophrenic thing I've ever read what are you talking about
like this is the manifesto of a skitso
stalker this is this is the equivalent but instead when you have
hundreds of millions of dollars or tens of millions of dollars.
Do you agree with what I've already said that he Ethan has a
case? I don't agree with Hassan at all if he's saying Ethan doesn't
have a case. Uh I would say parts of this lawsuit do read like
a literally schizophrenic manifesto. Absolutely. The idea of
like putting those pictures of Al Husini in there to make the
comparison with Hassan. Yeah, that is like borderline schizophrenic.
I don't understand at all. You get to hire a lawyer to put this
in a legal filing. This is also partially the reason why I think
a lawyer said it's just for the lawyers to eat up time so it
will cost more for them. That could be the case. But I also think
that this is ultimately such a silly lawsuit like such a frivolous
and stupid lawsuit that any any judge would look at this and
be like what the this is crazy especially considering that there
are so many instances where he has one mentioned that why do
you say that? What do you mean why do I say that? It's pretty
self-explanatory. Do you not understand lafo? Oh, this is oh
this is another person who's uh defending this uh insanely stupid
thing that is most likely not going to go anywhere. But it doesn't
matter. It doesn't have to go anywhere. This this lawsuit is
not about winning a a uh a serious award for some serious financial.
I think it was going to be a defamation or tort suit that was
re retrofitted to it was not windy. No, it wasn't. Um not even
remotely. You understand that he him registering the copyright
shows that he's been intending to do this like the whole time,
right? I don't know why you would think it's retrofitted in some
way. That that wouldn't make any sense. Harm that came to Ethan
Klein. That's not that's not it at all. And I think pretty much
every single person that is also advocating for this while cynically
claiming that this is like a super brave thing that Ethan is
doing and is a real game changer is doing so because they just
hate Frogan Caseyron and Denims. That's it. Why' you want to
ban them? Cuz I'm Oh, that's probably closer to true than false.
But yeah, it doesn't matter for the sake of I I think a lot of
people are defending this because they hate the people. I think
some people have said as much, right? Yeah. Well, maybe this
will change anything. Maybe it's like actually really threatening
to my career, like the stuff I do online. But you know what?
These people, I don't feel sympathy for them. I'm a freak. Every
L3 defender on Reddit is also we can stop pretending they're
separate communities. I mean, I don't think they are, but it
doesn't matter. If they win against him, they can get a compensation
from him for lawyer cause. Yeah, this is what E wants. Unlimited
harassment. Asmin Gold calls Trump for attacking other streamers
with lies. Predicts her life will only get worse after the lawsuits.
Yeah, this is this is what it is. this content for like literally
the grossest scumbags on the planet. It's not even about winning
a moral victory because he's openly saying he's doing it for
an uh Hold on. I'm going to use the bathroom real quick and then
I'm going to talk to this person who wants to argue about something.
So, give me two seconds. I'll be right back. Various reasons.
That's the worst part of all this. Oh, you know what? Hold on.
We need 10 minutes to finish this video. Maybe we'll finish this.
I should finish this video really quickly. Fans are just riding
for being evil. I guess evil maxing. Yeah, it's that simple.
They don't like Casey Tron. They don't like Frogan. Okay. They
have no principles. They don't care about the repercussions of
such a lawsuit if there was any sort of serious victory here
for Ethan and any sort of precedent that was set. And it is just
to churn out content for some of the grossest scumbags who get
off on hurting random content creators that they will never know
but they have identified as like enemies. And H3 just like any
other big male streamer who enables harassment will look at this
and go you brought this on to yourself and I don't control my
audience while whining how Hassan didn't ban every chatter who
called Ethan a genocide supporter. Oh yeah, that too. YouTube
inclines lead laws against Twitch streamer. Case John has brought
on such an onslaught of hate comments and wishes against her
that she says honestly it feels like people are trying to get
me to myself. They're even taking bets via Robin Hood on her
committing. The internet has made us so incredibly incredibly
awful. It's made us so not human. I saw a lawyer they say has
a good chance because all three stated they're streaming to have
a place for people to watch it without supporting Ethan. Like
I feel like especially for Morgan is like she's the primary focus
lawsuit. I mean not.
This is so goofy when he says this, right? He says it, but it's
like it's not real when he says it. Like he's saying all of this,
but it's it feels like complete. You supported the people like
kind of going after Ethan in the first place. Or at least you
didn't really like you didn't talk like that much trash about
them. I just feel like it's Yeah, people have lost their humanity.
People do lose their humanity online, but you participate in
that cycle like the whole time. And you participate in a way
where you like try to say you're not, but you really are like
the entire time. I wonder if some of the other material is stuff
he was planning to bring for quite a while. No, I don't I don't
think so, Wendy. I I don't think so. I don't see any reason to
believe that. I I don't know why why would why would you hire
a lawyer for like a defamation suit as a rich person, okay? And
then take that complaint and say, "No, no, no. Actually turned
into a copyright complaint when you were already planning to
file a copyright complaint." It doesn't make any sense. Content:
Ba is the sole provider for her disabled parents. They were blue
collar workers and are now elderly and rely on her. They did
not say that. Yeah, they did. Unfortunately, Ethan has been tagging
Robin Hood trying to get Robin Hood mad at Reddit for letting
people post about the bets. I went through a lot of negative
replies to Casey trying 90% were clearly right-wingers or Pesty
fans. No, I know. I think um even stating intent. I don't know.
I'm not a lawyer and I'm not a judge and uh I'm not engaged in
people should tag Robin Hood at to ask if they're aware that
Reddit is saying they take bets on if someone will commit suicide
and saying the Reddit last like fall to operate with impunity
tank like front page using Robin Robin Hood app. Dude, this is
like this is an insane person, dude. This is not like he is not
mentally well. I don't know. I don't know what else to say. He's
crashing out and hasn't stopped at all. I mean, it's a reasonable
position to have. I just wouldn't post about it personally cuz
you're going to give people like a lot of um uh like ideas on
how to with you, right? So, it's like alarming that there are
people who are I I think like it shows Ethan's not in control
of like his actions. Like he is like um he's sort of like rattled
and and like pointing out all of the things that upset him. But
hey, if he if he wants to do that, it's not like a weird thing
to be upset about. Hey, a bunch of people want to bet on my like
that seems uh who are fans of this sort of behavior. I'm going
to unban this guy again. Like it's not normal. especially when
he openly admitted that he wants to sue Shawn the Black and then
turned around and and hung over the head of uh two journalists,
two female journalists who implied that Ethan Klein is misogynistic
for unleashing a torrent of misogynistic hate towards these three
female contractors who was like suing maliciously, not for any
real purpose. And then he's like, "Oh, I'll drop the lawsuit
if they apologize." How much you want to bet even if they apologize,
he won't drop that lawsuit. He'll just claim he'll just claim
that it wasn't a sufficient apology or something because it's
literally about enforcing power. It's about it's about trying.
Uh no, Zezy, I don't know if you think it's I think it's so gross
that that Ethan's doing this where he's like, "If you guys dance
for me in just the way I like If you dance for me just the way
I like, then maybe I'll drop the lawsuit against Shawn. Maybe
I'll drop the Can you dance for me? Could you get on like webcam
and dance for me, Taylor Loren?" And then maybe maybe if you
do that, I drop the I dropped the lawsuit against Shawn. Uh,
yeah. Can you hear me stroking it right now, Taylor? He's like,
it's so gross. It's so
It's so weird, right? Like, what are you doing? What are you
doing? You sound You sound insane
to to have some kind of power over people. He will not he will
not actually drop this lawsuit or even decide to even fill this
lawsuit. This is just It's not about this lawsuit at all. Is
just about having power over people, thinking that he has power
over people. Why do people closest to him not get him help? Because
the people closest to him either don't give a and are enjoying
this or they're paid to be there. They're paid to baby him. This
is a powerless man who understands that he is no longer one of
the primary leaders of this content creation sphere and his relevance
is waning and his allies are marginal. So, he's desperate for
any sort of support he can get, which is why he's relying on
even gross. His allies are not marginal. What are you talking
about? He's basically totally aligned with like the other a politics
stream that's way bigger than you, right? I don't know what what
are we talking about? His allies are marginal, dude. Your allies
are marginal. That's uh Hassan is not analyzing this correctly
at all. I don't Okay. Gross right-wing figures. I kind of wonder
if he um if he's actually analyzing it incorrectly or if he just
wants people to believe that they're like not the underdogs.
I'm not sure. build some sense of community, not realizing the
long-term consequences that that will have on his own psyche
down the down the long run. His subscription count is going down,
his revenue sources are going down. I suspect even Teddy Fresh
is not doing well. And in that process, like one of the people
that he tried to take down, me, he sees not experiencing these
repercussions. So, he just changes priorities and he changes
targets against people who he could at least harm financially.
Not just content creators, but real life, Asmin has no IRL motion.
Uh, I think that's insane. I think Asmin Gold could absolutely
have a ton of IRL motion. I think I think he hasn't done it,
but I think it's crazy to think Asmin Gold doesn't have IRL motion
when all of his like viewers are all older people. I think that's
wild for simply even defending themselves in this frivolous litigation.
There's a video on TikTok with 3.4 24 million views of someone
destroying a Teddy Fresh hoodie. Yeah. So, this is his way of
striking out and lashing out like a petulant child, like a spoiled
little kid, and he wants to feel some kind of power. Guys, this
is the safe space right now to openly say Teddy Fresh hasn't
made a singular item that I can picture any actual human wearing
in a non-ironic way, if that makes sense. Like, who genuinely
is like waiting for the next drop? I'm being serious. Come out
now or else. 220,000 likes. There it is. No idea, Wendy. I have
no idea how to comment on whether it'll settle or not. So I I
literally don't know the pieces that would go into that analysis
for Ethan. I have no idea cuz like to me in my head I I think
Ethan wouldn't settle. But also maybe he would just settle and
like take a little bit of money from these people and just walk
away. Ethan makes another story post saying Taylor and Cass apologies.
Okay. Well, Ethan makes another post saying Taylor and Cassp
apologies aren't good enough. They both gave you apologies. You
don't get to dictate the language they use. That's not how that
works. You don't have to accept it and then but then it burdens
then the burden's on you. Ethan will never back down. He just
wants to grow who wants him to gravel. He's a sick abuser and
frankly he lives watching this happen to other women and posting
bikini pictures on the same vacation as your husband said harassing
other women is on some sick. Give it a rest man and just get
it back to Twitter. Get back on Twitter at this point if you're
using it by proxy and your subreddits is weird to not research
things yourself. Sarcastic non-apologies will not be accepted.
Snark I need a mod to sticky a post with a heartfelt apology.
Like dude, how pathetic do you It's so gross. It's so weird and
I I to me I don't know how there couldn't be something in the
legal system to deal with this. It's extremely weird. have to
be. How pathetic of a person are you where you're like me, this
subreddit that doesn't like me needs to also say, "This subreddit
also needs to apologize to me, but do it in a way where I feel
good about it." What can be done to remedy this type of situation?
Not much. Unfortunately, the best thing you can do is just like
avoid it, hope it goes away, or collective action. That's the
other thing. Like if if enough people if enough content creators
got together like back in the day when content creators did some
there was like a sense of community, right? there was a sense
of community and people would just like kind of handle it. They'd
be like, "What the [__] are you doing?" People get
like people would get yelled at quite a bit by large content
creators. There was a there was definitely a little bit of like
a so I does think that if uh if large content creators saw that
this was like a massive injustice that they wouldn't step in
like the the issue is is like I understand there is an argument
for Ethan here like hey these people have been unhinged towards
me. I can like kind of with them all like big content creators
will totally understand where Ethan's coming from. I think now
are they principled enough to stand up and say like also this
is this is wrong from like this point of view. Probably not.
They're large content creators. They probably don't really have
principles. As the sole owner of JTO Snark, I will never apologize
for anything. Just a heads up JTO. Okay. Rhox sticky a post right
now apologizing to me. Do it. Do it or I will continue on with
my non-existent lawsuit. Okay. Social pressure, right? There
was definitely a little bit of a social pressure that was created.
To be clear, my boy Ethan's move is 100% bad faith. How do you
justify watching Ethan in bad faith is my point? What? This is
what it used to. This is like under different circumstances back
in the day when [__] They're blatantly violating
copyright. It's hard to get behind them. Denims wasn't blatantly
violating copyright in the same way. That's just a lie and nobody
cares to look into it, right? That's like what it is is Denims
is not violating copyright in the same way. At least not in comparison
to like a ton of other people. It's just not it's not similar.
It's not the same. And it doesn't matter. It doesn't matter to
people, right? That that's the facts.
The denims thing is the most important thing. When I talk about
this, it's almost entirely with the denim suit in mind. Uh the
other ones I have not looked into anywhere near as much, so I
don't speak on them with anywhere near the confidence. I mostly
just say it seems like probably. With the Quatron one, I'm pretty
sure she's cooked. With the with the Frogen one, I think she
was doing like unrelated stuff and it was weird. You could argue
it's transformative, but I don't know. I don't know if she'll
get the same protections. I'm thinking the strongest argument
you have as Denims is saying that this is political commentary,
you are referenced, it's been a back and forth with the same
creator for a lot of the time and that while you were like saying
you you didn't want to give them views, you probably weren't
taking views. You weren't operating in the same like market pool
at all and like it was a and it was a political back and forth
that Ethan was participating in that he had engaged in that environment
completely. I don't know that the other people get that same
defense in the same way. I found the timeline in the doc, by
the way. It really does go through it and show show where she
admits to to the commentary being an afterthought.
Uh, if you want to link a screenshot of her saying that the commentary
was an afterthought, go ahead, Karate Moses. Did like this happen.
Uh, regardless, her her like intent doesn't matter if she's still
doing commentary, right? The intent again won't matter here.
It'll be whether or not it's fair use. Your intent to create
a market replacement does not mean you create a market
online, other content creators would be like, "This is unacceptable."
Like, even if it was a a known bad content creator, there were
certain things, there were certain lines you didn't cross, like
going after their advertisers, right? A lot of people who under
different circumstances would say, "No, I don't I don't like
this content creator, but I don't think you should go after their
advertisers." Like this kind of here's the base take. He should
have sued a lot of them. The lot of Yeah. A lot of people used
to stand up business on things like that. That's true. That's
true. No, because then he wouldn't be able to. I I can't believe
the uh the like mindset actually works for people here where
it's like, "No, no, no. Uh yeah, I'm principally against this.
It's actually really bad, but these people suck. These people
suck.
I I don't know where that mindset like comes into being. I don't
understand how you could do that as a content creator and like
get away with it." Dude, I listen. Yeah, I am principally against
this. I've always been principally against this, but Caseyron
really sucks. actually she really sucks to get support from them.
You that's you already admitted it's bad faith like Leafy is
here or there are numerous examples of people that were just
like cast aside as paras. But nowadays a lot of the people that
do speak out about this a lot of people that do speak out about
this kind of stuff are actually some of the most awful people
right it's Keemstar orbiters that rely on this constant cycle
of toxicity.
So even the good side of commentary YouTube just basically stays
quiet and a lot of the big content creators try to stay away
from this drama because they don't want that this kind of toxicity
to come their way which is understandable. Nobody wants this
kind of a psychopath up their ass all the time. But that's the
problem. The less people that is another thing is yeah basically
if you if you weigh in with a public opinion you're going to
have a litany of like on Twitter who are filling up your replies
forever.
Forever they will hate you over having the wrong opinion on this.
Okay. So, I do think a lot of other people, midsize creators,
are just staying away to stay away. They just don't want to be
involved. Full push back against people like this. Or even Asmin
Gold, for example. Uh, sorry. Marty Epstein, thank you for the
five gifted Dung Devils, Zezy, Mackenzie, Carter, Cameron, Drewie,
into the wannabe. All gifting us all getting a gifted sub from
Marty Epste. Marty, thank you. Thank you. Thank you. a whole
bunch of insane things that actually make this space that we
occupy a less safe space for a lot of our fans that are trans
or have undocumented family members or themselves or undocumented
or wait what how did he wait how did he get into this
kind of toxicity to come their way which is understandable nobody
wants how did he get how did he turn this into protecting like
trans and and uh like vulnerable minorities psychopath up their
ass all the time but that's the problem
people push back against people like this or even Asmin gold
for example for saying a whole bunch of insane things that actually
make the space that we occupy a less safe space for a lot of
our fans that are trans or have undocument oh just all of Asmin
Gold's listen when you don't push back against Asmin Gold's rhetoric
I don't think most big creators are are here for Asmin Gold uh
sorry are caping for Asmin Gold are like oh yeah when he when
he talked about going to the border and like catching people
in Pokemon balls that was that was so based I don't think there's
a lot of that members or themselves or on or not white you know
what I mean like when none of us push back against these large
content creators and all of the big content creators that normally
understand that this kind of thing is completely unacceptable
or even what Asthma Gold is doing is completely unacceptable
keeps silent. The only voices you hear create a new permission
structure that make it seem as though everyone actually has this
point of view. Everyone actually agrees with Ethan because the
only You struggle maintaining your principles when it comes to
people you hate. Do you even really have the principle? That
is the one of like one of the most crucial elements in is maintaining
it when it doesn't when it doesn't benefit you. Yeah, obviously.
Yeah, I know. Yeah. Exactly. Literally, that is the critical
that is a perfect point. BB Poison. Yes. The critical moment
for defining whether or not you have a principle, whether or
not something is right or wrong is whether you or not you're
willing to say, "Hey, that's actually really wrong when you do
it. That's actually really up." It's like one of the reasons
I can't like really like Mike from PA. It's like, dude, doing
like violent threats, even if it's like joking. Even if I think
in the uh in the Ethan case, he was like kind of what do you
call it? Like speaking metaphorically, it doesn't matter. Like
I I can't defend you if you're going to make those statements
on your on your public platform. is the people that I hear from
are people who agree with Ethan, right? Or the only people that
I hear from are people who agree with Asmin. And anyone who speaks
out against Asmin is is uh the recipient of an endless torrent
of hate. I try to explain to people that this depends on what
you speak out against Asmin on. You speak out against Asmin on
politics, a lot of people don't really care. They're like, "Whatever,
this guy's kind of on politics." You speak out against him when
he like complains about trans people being in video games, you
are going to die. You will have the most unhinched stalkers in
your DMs. Okay.
What what did we read like Alysa Mercante? Uh somebody talked
about her getting like by somebody who then started like eating
her. It was like a pack of black people her and then consuming
her flesh. It's like okay. All right. Listen, don't disagree
with Asmin Gold on trans people being in video games. Okay. That
is the line that I will never cross again. All right. That's
wild. Some of the DMs she got insane.
uh like content creators that this kind of silence in this circumstance
unironically creates a less safe environment for everyone including
themselves because these guys will eventually move on and will
go after someone else and eventually it'll be someone that you
love right or even if it's like Asmin and Ethan and I bracket
off in different ways like Asmin is just right-wing reactionary
and and is just so some of Hassan's Hassan's comments on the
lawsuit are pretty that it's like not going to go through or
might not be strong or it's like weak. I think he said it's almost
certainly not going to do any. I think that's complete. It will
have its desired effect basically no matter what. And but some
of the stuff around like morals, I don't believe he really believes
these things, but he's correct about them, right? He's he's saying
the right words. I don't know if he stands on them, but he is
saying the right words propaganda. Ethan is doing frivolous lawsuits
and litigation in a way that actually is like very harmful to
the space in a different way, right? He also does engage in some
reactionary tendencies as well, but like overall they're making
a more toxic environment. When content creators are afraid of
uh being involved in this because they see this as like toxic
drama, they don't realize but they end up creating a permission
structure for this kind of attitude to persist and that's it
and and it just keeps growing. It won't go anywhere unless people
push back. So what are we waiting for? You know, what are larger
content creators waiting for for someone to themselves after
this endless torren of hatred? Only then will they turn around
and say, "Oh, how could this have happened? How sad." You know,
so that you can in the aftermath when the dust is settled, when
it's actually appropriate for you to be able to say something,
when it's no longer considered toxic for you to say something,
will you then turn around and go, "Oh, who could have who could
have seen this?" Keemstar didn't stop with Etekica. And I suspect
Ethan won't stop either. You and Asmin should stream talk a bit
instead of reacting the clips of one another. Oh, I have. I've
asked. He avoids me like the plague. Don't Oh, he has asked as
gold to talk. That's interesting. That would be interesting having
them talk now. Okay, guys. I've got a bunch of other content
to do tonight, but I unfortunately have some real life stuff
going on. I I have to run unfortunately, but I will be back soon.
I I would hope later tonight, but I'm not I can't guarantee that.
Okay. I just have some stuff going. I will be back. I I will
be back eventually. Okay. At some point, I will be back. I Okay,
I will be back. I will be back. I will be back. I understand
it's a short stream, but I will be back. Okay. All
right. Okay. Sorry. I I I gotta go. I will be back at some point.
Possibly. Probably not tonight. Okay. Okay. I love you guys.
Bye.